the captain of the ship was taken to
face the media after his arrest
investigators want to know why after the
ship began to founder he told passengers
to stay in their cabins and not move he
says he thought he was doing the right
thing Oh London matters the current was
very strong and the water was cold I
thought if people left very too soon
that could be washed away who the rescue
ships had not yet arrived wasn't you
know but he was quick to bring himself
to safety the captain was among the
first survivors to be rescued at this
time almost 300 people were still
fighting for their lives on board is
sinking ship it seems unlikely that
anyone else has survived divers have
cited bodies in the wreck but are unable
to retrieve them to appease angry
relatives they are being shown images of
the dives there are strong currents poor
visibility and a wreck that is
constantly moving rescue workers are
also placing their own lives at great
risk raising the vessel with cranes
would help but it would also endanger
any survivors trapped inside even if you
now think this is likely young it we've
need the family's approval to do that
the government will seek their
permission family members have been
asked to submit DNA samples to allow
bodies to be identified quickly it's a
difficult step because it represents an
end to their hopes that their children
could still be alive